I'm working on personalizing text
recommendations for foreign language
earnings specifically that means how do
we take away the pain point of finding
articles that are your level of
difficulty in you because current work
doesn't personalize it doesn't account
for you as a user what vocabulary you
know what strengths and weaknesses you
have and the approach we're taking to
this is we're extracting certain
features from the articles modeling them
in a feature space and then we aim to
model the user in the same feature space
where we hope that a user that's close
to an article in the space will find
those articles of like a good level of
difficulty so now we're working to
develop an app for this and I'm
developing the back end and the
recommendation algorithm that delivers
these recommendations